- [Evan] Ego is the enemy.
"I don't like work, no man does,
"but I like what is in the work,
"the chance to find yourself."
Joseph Conrad.
For a full eight years, Winston Churchill
stood more or less by himself
against his shortsighted peers,
against the rising threat of
fascism, even among the West.
Welcome to the big show, folks.
Sometimes that is what it takes.
Sometimes we'll be forced to go it alone
because we've alienated
everyone around us.
Sometimes we'll be because
what we believe or do
is so new that there's no other choice.
Other times adverse will be environmental,
accidental, or just temporary.
There is no way around it.
We will experience difficulty.
We will feel the touch of failure.
All of us exist in this continuum.
We transition fluidly along it
at various points in our lives.
Perhaps we're born into privilege
and then aspire to something greater.
Perhaps we're born into great difficulty
or start off on the wrong foot
and then begin to pick up the pieces.
Or more commonly, we set out in life
hoping to do great
things, achieve success,
undermine that success,
and find ourselves
learning important lessons,
as we seek to rebuild and recapture.
But right now we're at
failure and it sucks.
Whatever junction we're on
one thing dogs us - ego.
It makes all the steps hard
and it makes failure the hardest.
It leads us to failure
and then abandons us.
We're afraid to lose and fail
because we think it
says something about us.
It doesn't.
Success didn't either.
All the failure says is that
there was a chance to improve
and better understand yourself.
What we need to see is
that we are not failures,
we're just experiencing failure.
Where you're going next
or how long you'll be here
no one can say.
If ego accompanies you
it will seek out failure like true north.
It is its own worst enemy.
It is your enemy.
Ego is the enemy.